hi I'm Erik Bosse and if interested
finding two we're broke our hearts so
cruelly that many of us are still in
that weird denial stage of grief for
example not long after the movie came
out a theory went around that Loki did
not actually get his neck snapped by
Thanos but that he had actually
disguised himself as the Hulk and dannis
merely chiropractor to projection sound
far-fetched shut up we're grieving and
by the way go watch my video on that
theory because it affects this theory
because now with the Infinity Ward
digital HD release our conspiracy
theories have 1080 lines of resolution
and razor-sharp background details to
help us evade objective reality and many
of you have been reaching out to me once
again about Loki and new details that
have emerged with the recent infinity
war release could Loki still be alive
did he fake his death well let's talk
about it let's get that proof ok the
shot people are talking about is in the
first sequence of infinity war after
Thanos beats down Hulk and kills
Heimdall and Loki steps out to try to
sneak attack Thanos with a dagger nano
stops them with a space stone and he
chokes into death but if you look very
closely at the background you can see a
very subtle shadow in the space outside
the ship some have said that that shadow
could be Loki Loki perhaps wearing his
signature war helmet with the large
horns that curve upwards the idea this
theory is that this Loki that we see die
is just a projection and that the god of
mischief is observing this all go down
from outside the ship it's kind of like
that Hulk Loki theory just without the
Hulk apart now it's not just a shadow
that the theorists are buzzing about
there were Loki spinal boards to Thor
earlier in the sequence
I assure you brother the Sun will shine
on us again and people are wondering why
Loki as a brilliant tactician would
think just jabbing the dagger at Thanos
would work or why he would use his left
hand since they argue most other times
he appears to use his right hand and I
gotta admit while I rewatched his scene
Loki's eyeline might be a little too
veered to the left
possibly past Thanos his eyes to the
real version of himself outside now look
I have been fooled before by marvel and
Loki hasn't done himself any favors in
the past by faking his death before and
masquerading as other characters so let
us at least try to give this theory its
due what would this mean for Avengers 4
well it would vindicate Loki's dying
words to Thanos
[Music]
Mookie's trick would prove that the mad
Titan despite all the universe altering
power he gains in this movie still has
limits in blind spots that the power of
demigods like Thor and Loki still
escapes Thanos is grasped I think it
would also mean that all the characters
we saw die pre-snap are back in the
toss-up category already it looks like
characters who faded away won't be dead
after all and it's increasingly sounding
like Gamora or at least a ghost of her
will continue to be a presence that
haunts Thanos from inside the soul stone
with butterfly kisses
it would also more closely follow the
unkillable presence Loki appears to be
in the Marvel comics like many villains
and heroes no one ever really stays dead
for long like killing characters and
resurrecting them in the comics is all
kind of part of a cycle to raise stakes
and repeat over and over again to sell
more and more issues and with infinity
war Marvel head Kevin Feige has proved
he's not afraid to dramatize the most
implausible twists from the comic panels
this whole Avengers saga film series has
gambled on that premise that movies
could work like comics and that Gamble
has paid off here's the issue though
this Avengers infinity war digital
release didn't just enable us to scour
the background for high-res details it
also included a pretty good commentary
track by the filmmakers and when it came
to the decision to kill off Loki this is
what they said director Joe Russo said
part of one we wanted to do out of the
gate was to unsettle you as you're
watching the film you're sitting in the
theater thinking most characters in
Marvel Universe have been safe for a
decade we wanted to knock you off kilter
and make the audience understand that
these stakes were going to be
significant and the cost was going to be
very high in the movie so they wouldn't
just show their nose immediately taking
out the current reigning champ the one
major villain who still managed to get
away all to declare that there is a new
even more dangerous villain in town so
those are real emotional stakes that the
writers and directors not long and hard
about and it just makes too much sense
for this all to be some cover story for
a really implausible fake death twist
that would probably piss everyone off
you know sorry to rain on this parade
too much but that shadow outside the
ship it looks a lot like the floating
pieces of debris that we saw at the
beginning of the sequence drifting away
from the as guardianship as Stannis
forces attacked so this might just be
another case of that hanging munchkin in
the background of The Wizard of Oz
theory
you remember that fan theory that was
the one where people thought that they
saw munchkin hanging himself in the
background of a scene of The Wizard of
Oz all out of some we're done requited
love with Judy Garland
turns out no it was just a big stupid
bird which the set dresser released into
the set for the scene
the reason this theory exists is some
jerk edited footage to add a shadow in
the shape of a hanging body that made
the rounds in the 90s and left a ton of
people convinced that a bunch of actors
and set crew people and editors and
directors are all incapable of seeing a
hanging body prominently in the
background of a movie even though by the
way this would have been impossible
because all the Munchkins scenes were
shot way later in production and none of
these actors would have been on set yet
but guys the truth is boring and besides
both parts of that theory were wrong
that hanging munchkin was totally just
loki is using the time stone to go back
in time to 1938 a time stone that was
also just a projection when dr. strange
gave it to Thanos dannis by the way was
first spotted lumbering around in
Northern California in the 60s 9/11 a
question for you guys
if Loki did faked his death what do you
think would be the coolest way for him
to a return in Avengers 4 maybe in the
post-credits scene of Captain Marvel
smacking into a Kree warship like his
brother did to the guardians or maybe
sneaking into Thanos is barn while he
sleeps and slipping on that charred
gauntlet saying I hope do it myself or
maybe rocket will just play weekend at
bernie's of Loki's corpse for two and a
half hours look if you're so desperate
for him to come back you gotta be open
to anything comment down below with your
thoughts or tweet me directly at da BOTS
with your thoughts on all this stuff and
follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
shared around and subscribe to new
rockstars and you know double check to
see that you are subscribed YouTube's
randomly unsubscribing people from
channels these days and hit that Bell
icon to make sure that you're getting
notifications
thank you for watching and you know what
Loki's still alive hours don't listen to
the non-believers the truth is out there
[Music]